Só quật nổ phê khối,
ô tổ bị quân trôi.
Quên rất phí lý pin lào máy nhà chính gần
thì bảo cảnh mại gì quát quà miền chúng nước này.
Theo cơ quà bị tượng quốc gia phí lý pin,
bảo cả ra bảo cảnh mại gì,
tên điệp phương tino, đồ bộ vào tính năm nay tê
đêm 3 tháng 14 giặt sáng 14.
Măng theo gió mại 1,5% giật tới 2,5%
phó đông quà lý và giảm nhẹ dù gió thân tài quốc gia cho biết
đến chưa bún tháng 14,5%
hình của mình là thuộc dân này điện.
Sống khao bà mẹt ngoài khơi xả mà và lấy tê
kiến một chăm linh tám cảm biển nâng mặt đầu
ít nhất về lâm chuyện bài đội điện bị huy.
Cảnh sát viện khu vực Trung Phi sẽ giác
tãn nâng thành bảo lên mức đó,
vì đặc hơn nằm chăm năm 2019,
cùng phương tiện dù hộ.
Đây là cơn bảo thứ 2 mười tấn công phí lý pin trong năm nay,
có nghĩ đạo gần Trung với xíu bảo thay yến,
năm hàng yên không chăm mấy bà,
khiến gần sống nơi tệt mặt.
Khao chung tâm sự bảo khi tượng thủy bàn cuối gia Việt Nam,
sau khi vượt qua phí lý pin bảo càn mà ở gí
đi vào biển đông với tưởng đội các mùi bún
khả năng tổ bộ của vượt quảng gái đến các lắc.